we're back again
uh the first time we read from our diaries our secrets
um it was a it was a so embarrassing
but it was a bit of a hit
it was so we thought we would maybe do a part two and um
get a little further in oh
this is about the Dairy Queen ugh
I absolutely hate Teddy
I said his name
um I'm really happy I found this out cause he is a total loser
and David was trying to get Teddy to ask me out and he goes
well I would but her parents probably work at Dairy Queen
wow I remember it almost exactly right then
then Jordan goes
well look at it this way
at least you would get free blizzards
I'm so glad I don't like him anymore
I so quickly didn't like him anymore
I wish him ill
I actually feel a little validated because it was worse because there were like
there was collusion
these diaries are dangerous
dangerous this is a lot of danger
okay let's hear
I say it's boring to go out with a boy
you don't do anything
you're super shy
and one day you're gonna break up
ha ha ha thanks for tuning in to Liz and Monica's sad diary yeah